cinemasins is about to pass 1 million
subscribers people does 10 months ago
this would happen we would have said
you're crazy am i or am i so saying that
you just blew your mind it's impossible
or is it so possible that your head is
spinning like it can't be your entire
world just crashing down but seriously
you people are awesome so to celebrate
this milestone we're letting you guys
pick a special sins movie choice
the problem is choice now we have a cool
idea for the Star Wars prequels and we
don't want to jinx it so we're taking
those off the table we've taken the top
15 movies we get requested to find
everything wrong with and now's your
chance to push one through and get it on
the schedule just go to cinema since
calm slash vote or if you're really lazy
just click this button here after seven
days we'll announce the winner and then
you'll see this ins video for that movie
the following week remember if you don't
vote your life will probably stay
relatively the same so what are you
waiting for go focus is your time now go
out there and take it